text reducing health disparities with
technology appears over a train yard in
winter
school bus passes in front of a building
with entrance door labeled south central
educational development inc text opioid
overdose workshop south central
educational development inc sced
december 2019 overlay's entrance door
the goal of this workshop is to have
community prepared to respond to opioid
overdoses
we need to be able to address this issue
from the ground up
seated workshop attendees listen to
daryl kennedy director of the sced text
daryl kennedy executive director south
central educational development inc
south central was started out of the
need for hiv education in southern west
virginia and it was actually developed
as a organization that targeted african
americans scenes of town streets and
homes on drury winter day scene changes
to kennedy entering a storage room and
as we got out and we were doing the work
in rural communities it was
very evident that everyone needed it so
we moved from a minority-based program
to a general population program we are
funded through the national library of
medicine they have been supporting our
technology programs here in the building
close up of printed medline plus
brochure and other medical information
and their mission is presenting high
quality wellness information that is
trusted easy to understand and free
brief scene of kennedy and nguyen
talking to two male workshop attendees
tony nguyen jones speaking text tony wen
executive director and nlm southeastern
atlantic region we first became
connected with sced in 2012
their first application from us was
based on community outreach to reduce
health disparities and stigmas seated
woman looks at computer screen then we
realized that there is a need for
technology because having a computer lab
available for people at a community
center where they can look up health
information in general was really
important
tods acronym is spelled out vertically
then defined horizontally technology
outreach reduce disparities stigma
project towards its technology outreach
to reduce health disparities being able
to access the national library of
medicine's database gives us tools to
help teach people how they can go and
find information
dr gregory kane shown speaking
text dr gregory kane bluefield regional
medical center you know there's not a
lot of opportunities here this is an
area that really lacks in resources the
south central education
development
is the only one around here having any
impact
snow covered hilly countryside on a
heavily overcast day against heavily
overcast sky text appears project
towards is connecting rural communities
with access to accurate quality health
and prevention information and education
to help reduce hiv infections in
southern west virginia and provide
drop-in centers for high-risk
populations actively involved in drug
recovery
nih nlm logo serving scientists and
society